moi je pense que je peux dire que je me
considère comme quelqu'un dans le mal
être parce que covin j'ai l'impression
d'avoir raté une bonne partie
de ma jeunesse et donc le démarrage
d'où l'importance pour moi de devenir
aussi ici après alcôves il
est malade
prends du recul
m
j'ai l'impression d'être
dans une régression totale enfermée chez
moi à pas pouvoir voir personne pouvoir
plus rien faire je pouvais plus rien
faire
du coup je me sentais totalement
dépossédé de
la jeunesse est de ma vie parce que j'ai
la vingtaine et que c'est le moment où
on a envie de sortir rencontrer des gens
faire la fête
[Musique]
on a constaté une augmentation de
demandes de soutien psychologique depuis
ces cinq dernières années mais une
aggravation des signes de mal être
essentiellement depuis septembre 2021
avec beaucoup de troubles anxio
dépressifs chez les jeunes il ya
vraiment une incertitude chez eux qui
qui les met en mal être profond
de plus en plus tôt
on trouvait que c'était important que
nos enfants aient accès à des
psychologues diplômés d'état enfin des
psychologues de métier et que c'était
bien que c'est c
une association interviennent de
l'extérieur en fait soit pas dans le
cadre ni du lycée ni de la famille pour
que nos enfants soient libres de
discuter avec ces psychologues de leur
plein gré
[Musique]
c'est un point écoute qui permet aux
jeunes de venir rencontrer des
psychologues ou psychologue stagiaires
et est en fait d'avoir un premier
contact avec un psy ça va parce que
c'est souvent un peu
difficile pour un adolescent de faire
tout le chemin pour atteindre les psy
elle d'une certaine manière appelé
pendant rendez vous c'est des choses qui
sont pas forcément évidentes
voilà six jours on sentait pas très bien
ou si vous avez un pote qui vous voyez
pas dans son assiette quoi que ce soit
[Musique]
c'est tout aussi l'effet de
tabou de la situation le mal est déjà
n'est encore que je suis là on n'en
parle pas parce que ça fait peur parce
que ça va pas forcément ensemble
[Musique]
à